rätselhafte orte manche zerstört oder
verseucht vom menschen verlassen einige
wirken idyllisch andere gespenstisch
eines haben sie alle gemeinsam sie
erzählen eine geheimnisvolle geschichte
einige häuser sind gefährlich nah an die
krippen gebaut direkt vor der tür geht
es steil runter
hast du sogar die badewannen sind voll
sand die wüste holt sich die stadt
zurück
[Applaus]
zurück bleiben die spuren von krieg
naturkatastrophen
oder anderen gravierenden ereignissen
die ganze stadt ist mit einer
rätselhaften schicht überzogen
hier ist etwas unvorstellbares passiert
die fünf geheimnisvollsten geisterstädte
der welt alle längst verlassen
in ihren verfallenen bauten sind die
echos der vergangenheit hörbar
einige erzählen vom dunklen zeiten
an diesen orten pulsierte einst das
leben dann wurden sie aufgegeben
[Musik]
wer hat sie gebaut
wer hat hier gelebt und warum sind die
bewohner nicht geblieben
[Musik]
im süden argentiniens ist ein seltsamer
unheimlicher ort
es sieht aus wie nach der apokalypse
in der einzige zugang ist eine straße
voller schlaglöcher man kriege gänsehaut
es ist unheimlich
an es ist mit weißem staub überzogen und
die bäume wirken wie versteinert übrig
schwer zu sagen was hier geschehen ist
[Musik]
als
hätte jemand mit den fingern geschnippt
und schlagartig alles verzaubert eine
wahre geisterstadt
treppen führen ins nichts häuser sind
verfallen
die karge leblose landschaft verrät uns
nicht was mit dieser stadt passiert ist
einen hinweis aber gibt die weiße
substanz die alles bedeckt
sein sind hier bomben gefallen und wenn
ja warum gab es überlebende was ist hier
geschehen
es gibt schwimmbäder und die überreste
von cafés
spielplätze mit schaukeln und rutschen
die wie erstarrt wirken wie am set für
einen horrorfilm
eine militärbasis kann es nicht gewesen
sein im gegenteil das war mal ein sehr
hübscher ort
hier könnte ein feuer gewütet haben
oder steckt etwas ganz anderes hinter
der seltsamen weißen schicht
[Musik]
die stadt wirkt wie ausgestorben
fast
denn es gibt noch einen bewohner der den
rätselhaften ort nicht verlassen hat
[Musik]
mein name ist pablo nowak ich bin der
einzige der hier noch lebt ich bin hier
geboren genau wie meine beiden brüder
am 25 januar bin ich 88 geworden
[Musik]
seit jahren lebt nowak alleine hier
er war der einzige der nicht aufgeben
wollte
[Musik]
ich blieb und war sicher dass die leute
irgendwann zurückkommen würden früher
war dieser ort sehr beliebt die leute
kamen von überall her
[Musik]
heute ist es nur noch schwer vorstellbar
aber jahrzehntelang war dies ein
beliebter erholungsort für die reichen
bewohner der argentinischen hauptstadt
buenos aires
tausende verbrachten hier ihren urlaub
[Musik]
es gab sogar eine bahnlinie nach buenos
aires
mitte des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts war
er ein beliebter ferienort mit bis zu
25.000 besuchern pro jahr
noch heute sieht man warum die menschen
gerne her kamen sie wollten zum see das
mineralreiche wasser soll eine heilende
wirkung gehabt haben doch das wasser
wurde der stadt zum verhängnis
dies ist was von dem einstigen kurort
via apple wenn noch übrig ist
immer schon haben orte mit heißen und
mineralischen quellen große faszination
auf die menschen ausgeübt sie gelten als
besonders gesund
der legende nach entstand der see aus
den tränen eines häuptlings der seiner
großen liebe nach weinte
die heilende kraft des sees war seit
jahrhunderten bekannt angeblich halver
gegen ganz unterschiedliche krankheiten
von depressionen bis rheumatismus
aus einem verschlafenen dorf wurde ein
quirliges touristen ziel
die wenigsten besucher ahnen dass das
heil bringende wasser eine geheime
gefahr birgt
die stadt wächst und wächst neue hotels
werden gebaut sogar ein schlachthaus um
die fleisch versorgung sicherzustellen
und der ort bietet jede menge
attraktionen
[Musik]
das hier war ursprünglich ein ballsaal
später wurde er auch als theater genutzt
theaterensembles aus buenos aires trat
nie auf
ein touristenparadies mit einer
scheinbar glänzenden zukunft bis das
schicksal zuschlägt
im november
1985 begann es zu regnen und es hörte
nicht mehr auf
es war ein rekordregen der sie drohte
über die ufer zu treten
der soeben noch die attraktion von webo
in wird zur bedrohung bei
großen binnengewässern gibt es ein
besonderes phänomen
die so genannte seuche
wir kennen das aus der badewanne wir
bewegen uns und plötzlich schafft uns
das wasser ins gesicht
der grund dafür sind viele sogenannte
stand wellen die sich zu einer größeren
welle verbinden
[Musik]
etwas ähnliches ist denn wir ab was
passiert die welle war so hoch dass sie
alle barrieren überwinden konnte
den bewohnern bleibt nichts anderes
übrig als aus der stadt zu fliehen
zum glück stieg das wasser nur langsam
an die menschen hatten zwar nicht viel
zeit aber sie reichte den 1500
einwohnern um ihre sachen zu packen
[Musik]
die fluten verschlangen die stadt nach
und nach
1993 lag der wasserpegel bei zehn metern
via epic win wurde zu einem modernen
atlantis
[Musik]
alles was wir heute sehen war 20 jahre
lang verschwunden
[Musik]
im lauf der zeit zieht sich das wasser
langsam zurück
die einstmals heilenden salze
hinterlassen ihre spuren auf den
trümmern
[Musik]
natürlich waren viele gebäude
eingestürzt und dazu kam diese
unheimliche weiße schicht die auf allem
lag
zurück blieb eine dicke salzschicht
es sah aus als wäre die stadt nach einer
bombardierung mit asche bedeckt
dieselben mineralien mit denen die leute
hier einst versuchten ihre beschwerden
zu lindern bedeckten die ganze stadt
[Applaus]
obwohl via epo in inzwischen fast
komplett wieder aufgetaucht ist gibt es
für die stadt kein zurück mehr zu den
glorreichen zeiten
pablo nowak will trotzdem bleiben
als ich 70 wurde schenkten meine töchter
mehr geld weil sie dachten ich kann hier
nicht alleine leben
jetzt bin ich 88 und immer noch da
solange ich mich auf den beinen halten
kann bleibe ich
auf einer bergkuppe im süden italiens
ragt mitten in der kargen landschaft ein
gespenstisch wirkende ort empor
der fels liegt mitten im ödland da lebt
weit und breit kein mensch
trotzdem ist da in knapp 500 metern höhe
eine bemerkenswerte statt
[Musik]
ein atemberaubender anblick schwer zu
sagen wo der fels aufhört und die häuser
anfangen
die stadt ist regelrecht mit dem berg
verwachsen
einige häuser sind genau an den rand des
hangs gebaut direkt vor der tür geht es
steil nach unten
die bauarbeiten müssen wahnsinnig
anstrengend gewesen sein die bekamen sie
die steine über die felsvorsprünge die
braucht man sowas überhaupt
aus der nähe betrachtet tauchen weitere
mysteriöse details auf
[Musik]
die häuser sind ziemlich ramponiert die
kuppel der kirche fehlt komplett der ort
wurde regelrecht platt gemacht man fragt
sich was war hier los ein bombenangriff
gab es überleben
[Musik]
die verwitterten gebäude lassen erahnen
dass hier jahrhundertelang menschen
gelebt haben
[Musik]
fremdenführer saverio
erklärt was diesen ort so besonders
macht
[Musik]
hier oben auf dem turm versteht man
sofort die strategische bedeutung dieses
ortes
von hier aus lässt sich die umgebung
sehr gut überwachen man hat einen
rundumblick
[Musik]
das ist krakow oder besser gesagt das
was von dem mittelalterlichen krakow
übrig geblieben ist
[Musik]
der älteste teil der stadt ist zugleich
auch der am besten erhaltene er wurde
auf solidem untergrund errichtet um
militärischen angriffen stand zu halten
der wuchtige turm mit seinen
schießscharten und befestigungen dann
kommt offenbar aus der zeit als piraten
das mittelmeer unsicher machen
das ganze dorf war eine
verteidigungsanlage
bei genauerem hinsehen erkennt man dass
es sich nicht nur um mittelalterliche
ruinen handelt vieles kommt aus der
neuzeit
noch vor kurzem haben da menschen gelebt
die frage lautet wie wurde die
gemeinschaft zerstört und warum
ironischerweise führt karakus
wirtschaftlicher erfolg auch zu seinem
untergang
im 15 jahrhundert ziehen reiche
landbesitzer in die stadt weiß
bürgermeister pino giandomenico
sich der ort zu einer richtigen stadt
sie wuchs rund um den turm herum
am rand standen die häuser der
grundstücksbesitzer
in den folgenden jahrhunderten floriert
krakow auch auf den angrenzenden hügeln
werden häuser gebaut
heute sind sie allerdings verschwunden
es fällt auf dass die neueren teile
verschwunden sind während die altstadt
immer noch weitgehend intakt ist
die frage ist warum das ganze aussieht
wie ein kriegsgebiet
linie an der alte und neue gebäude
zusammentreffen liegt heute gut drei
meter tiefer als damals
der ganze ort ist zusammengeschrumpft
erklären lässt sich dieses erstaunliche
phänomen mit den bodenverhältnissen
während die mittelalterlichen gebäude
auf solidem fels errichtet wurden stehen
die jüngeren worten auf weniger festem
boden
und sie üben erheblichen druck auf den
untergrund aus die folge erdrutsche
ein erdrutsch ist das abgleiten von erd-
und gesteinsmassen
verursacht wird er durch das eindringen
von wasser in vorher gebundene
bodenschichten
erdrutsche waren hier im ort keine
seltenheit die häuser wurden repariert
dann ging das leben weiter
[Musik]
anfang 1960 werden bauern eingezogen um
die neueren häuser zu schützen
aber die erde gibt keine ruhe
[Applaus]
1961 1963 hatten erdrutsche großen
schaden angerichtet
der komplette neue teil des dorfs war
runter ins tal gerutscht und der
fußballplatz und die schutzmauer waren
verschwunden
ironischerweise sind die schäden
weitgehend selbst verschuldet
sie hatten die häuser mit schwerem beton
untermauert was tiefe bohrungen
notwendig machte das zusätzliche gewicht
verstärkte die erdrutsche noch
undichte leitungen führten dazu dass
wasser ins erdreich eindringen konnte
die feuchtigkeit trug zur entstehung der
erdrutsche bei es war also ein menschen
gemachtes problem dass schließlich zur
evakuierung der stadt führte
erdrutsche mögen die neueren teil across
auf dem gewissen haben doch wodurch
wurde die altstadt so radikal zerstört
die habe proben juve krakow liegt in
einem erdbebengebiet
der mann sie können sich vorstellen wie
ein haus zittert das auf einem
zitternden felsen steht
1980 gab es ein starkes erdbeben
die zerstörungen machten die stadt
praktisch unbewohnbar
in diesem haus hat eine familie bis
anfang der 90er jahre gelebt
da drin sind immer noch ein ofen stühle
und sogar flaschen neben dem kamin
[Musik]
nach fast 1000 jahren erlebte krakow
eine serie von schicksalsschlägen die
einfach zu viel waren
[Musik]
heute ist cargo eine geisterstadt
und ein unheimliches ziel für
wissbegierige touristen
es gab nie versuche die stadt wieder
aufzubauen
das macht sie für menschen interessant
die einen ganz ursprünglichen
mittelalterlichen ort erleben wollen
kaco diente auch als drehort für einige
filme wir zeigen will wie jerusalem vor
2000 jahren aussah der ist hier genau
richtig
auch für die wissenschaft ist cargo von
unschätzbarem wert
nach allem was die stadt durchgemacht
hat ist sie zu einem mekka für die
forschung geworden was führt zur
zerstörung einer intakten statt und wie
konnte man das verhindern
hoffen wir dass sich für die zukunft
etwas daraus lernen lässt
[Musik]
in einem abgelegenen wald im norden der
ukraine stehen die überreste einer
ehemals topmodernen statt der damaligen
sowjetunion
150 leerstehende von pflanzen
überwucherten gebäude auf einer fläche
von 40 quadratkilometern
eins scheint der ort alles zu besitzen
was eine aufstrebende stadt braucht
aber dann fällt er einer der schlimmsten
katastrophen der jüngeren geschichte zum
opfer
der ort entsteht in den 70er jahren als
vorzeigeobjekt der sowjetunion
wie andere ähnlich konzipierte städte
soll es die hellsten köpfe und
engagiertesten arbeiter des landes
anlocken
es ist platz genug für über 50.000
einwohner
[Musik]
einer davon sergej chernoff
die stadt war gut geplant mit schöner
umgebung und großartiger infrastruktur
es war eine stadt für junge leute das
durchschnittsalter lag bei 26 jahren
überall finden sich hinweise auf jene
technologie wegen der die stadt
errichtet wurde
um die später zu ihrer vernichtung führt
[Musik]
das ist das stadtzentrum mit dem
sogenannten kulturpalast energetik
da drüben auf dem fünfstöckigen gebäude
steht der slogan möge das atomarbeiter
und nicht soldat seien
bekanntlich nicht so recht geklappt
das ist privat jene stadt die als
wohnort für die arbeiter im
kernkraftwerk tschernobyl errichtet
wurde
reaktor 4 ist explodiert und die
strahlung verteilt sich über weite teile
europas mit einem anstieg der
strahlungsintensität wird in den
kommenden wochen gerechnet
regiert wird evakuiert
8000 menschen sterben beim schlimmsten
reaktorunglück aller zeiten
das komplette areal wird gesperrt der
ort hört schlagartig auf zu existieren
zurück bleibt eine verwaiste
geisterstadt
es war riskant eine stadt direkt neben
einem atomkraftwerk zu bauen aber damals
wurde das ebenso gemacht kricket ist der
beweis wie falsch das war
[Musik]
im westen namibias existiert eine
weitere rätselhafte geisterstadt mitten
in einer kargen wüstenlandschaft
die gebäude tauchen plötzlich wie aus
dem nichts zwischentönen und felsen auf
[Musik]
[Applaus]
displays dieser ort ist so sesam
du bist mitten in der wüste und sie ist
plötzlich eine westernstadt
aber wenn du genau hinschaut ist die
schon etwas moderner
architektur macht durchaus etwas her da
fragt man sich woher kam das geld für so
elegante bauten
zu seiner zeit war der ort definitiv
angesagt aber warum
geld und menschen sind verschwunden die
natur holt sich die stadt zurück
da sind badewannen voller sand zimmer
voller sand
hier ist nur noch die wüste zu hause
da sind nur noch schlangen und skorpione
wer zum teufel wollte hier leben
auch brutaler sandstürme und akuter
wassermangel konten der stadt nichts
anhaben im gegenteil die menschen lebten
hier offenbar sehr komfortabel
das war eine wohlhabende stadt
es gab eine eisfabrik für die kühltruhen
ein fleischer einfach alles was die
bewohner so brauchten
warum zogen die menschen ausgerechnet
hierher und wieso ist es heute eine
geisterstadt
wer also erbaute unter so feindseligen
bedingungen eine stadt mit allem drum
und dran
anfang des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts ist
das heutige namibia teil von deutsch
südwestafrika
das zum britischen empire gehörende
kapstadt ist rund 800 kilometer entfernt
es ist durch eine bahnlinie mit
hafenstadt lüderitz verbunden
es war eine unerschlossene gegend am
ende der welt
um so einen ort zu besiedeln brauchst du
eine sache unbedingt einen rohstoff
dieser rohstoff wird bald gefunden
1908 entdeckte ein arbeiter diamanten im
sat
das änderte alles
es ist die geburtsstunde einer neuen
stadt
willkommen in kohlmann scope in namibia
[Musik]
eine stadt die ihren bewohnern trotz
unwirtlicher bedingungen einigen luxus
zu bieten hat
hier wohnte die ladenbesitzerin
sie war die reichste frauen kommen scope
hier sind ihre importe aus deutschland
aufgelistet
ganz erstaunliche produkte von carmen b
bis zum teuersten champagner
dass die stadt sehr vermögend war ist
offensichtlich
diese häuser waren sehr raffiniert
designt
zwischen die ziege wurde holz verbaut
das funktionierte wie eine natürliche
klimaanlage
die es mit den hohen
temperaturunterschiede in der wüste
aufnehmen konnte
wieso hat diese oase dann keine zukunft
zunächst ist sie ein magnet für deutsche
abenteurer die hier ihr glück machen
wollen
wir stellen uns diamant minen als
aufwendige konstruktionen vor aber so
war das nicht ebenfalls nicht am anfang
die männer kochen im mondlicht auf allen
vieren durch den sand und suchten nach
den glitzersteinen und wurden fündig
man erzählte sich dass die männer damals
nur gräben ausheben mussten es gab so
viele diamanten dass man sie nun die
gräben fegen und einsammeln musste
1912 gab es in kohlmann scope eines der
weltweit grössten diamantenvorkommen
[Musik]
kohlmanns group entwickelte sich schnell
zu einer florierenden diamanten statt
auf dem höhepunkt wurden ihr zwölf
prozent der weltweiten produktion
geschärft
brilliante zeiten für die wüstenstadt
trotz der lebensfeindlichen umgebung
hatte die stadt einiges zu bieten
es gab eine kegelbahn
opernsänger aus europa traten auf
es gab sogar in meerwasserschwimmbad
mitten in der wüste
es gab ein theater ein konzerthaus die
deutsche kultur war hier allgegenwärtig
aber ein problem überschattet den
wohlstand
wassermangel
kommen scope und lüderitz hatten kein
eigenes fischwasser etwas grundwasser
aber das reichte nicht für alle es
vertrauen und es hat sich
darum dass es der wasserspeicher von
kollmann scope das wasser wurde aus
kapstadt importiert
1000 tonnen frisches wasser pro monat
so lange in kurmann scope viel geld
verdient wird auch dank der
unterstützung durch die briten ist der
wasser import unproblematisch aber in
europa droht ein krieg wie lange werden
die engländer noch kooperieren und was
soll ohne wasser aus der stadt werden
[Musik]
in den guten zeiten verfügt kohlmanns
kopf über die modernste technologie
seinerzeit
worauf es in der stadt damals wirklich
ankam erkennen wir daran dass es dort
den ersten röntgenapparat in ganz
südafrika gab
und der war nicht dazu da knochenbrüche
zu diagnostizieren damit wurde überprüft
ob jemand bei der arbeit einen diamanten
runtergeschluckt hatte
die dramatischen ereignisse des jahres
1914 stellen einen ersten wendepunkt dar
nach dem ausbruch des ersten weltkriegs
1914 wurden viele deutsche eingezogen
und mussten ihre heimat zurückkehren
noch bedeutsamer aber waren die
diamanten funde an der mündung des
oranier flusses die diamanten dort waren
sechs mal so groß wie die aus kollmann
scope
da kommen scope erledigt
als die leute hörten dass da unten noch
mehr zu holen war wissen sie alles
stehen und liegen und gingen nach süden
thomas cook hält noch einige jahre durch
bis 1956
dann sind die letzten diamanten
geschärft und auch der letzte bewohner
verlässt die stadt die wüste übernimmt
das regime
heute herrscht gespenstische ruhe in
kollmar scope das trockene klima sorgt
dafür dass die gebäude immer noch
erstaunlich gut erhalten sind
die diamanten allerdings sind anderswo
in namibia werden immer noch diamanten
abgebaut nicht weit von kollmann scope
entfernt wurden sogar auf dem
meeresgrund welche entdeckt
[Musik]
in columbia county im us-bundesstaat
pennsylvania gibt es eine stadt die fast
komplett vom erdboden verschwunden ist
es ist sofort klar dass da irgendwas
gewaltiges passiert sein muss
die stadt ist das opfer von etwas im
grunde unvorstellbaren
da sind keine menschen mehr
unheimlich
die rechtwinklig angelegten straßen
deuten darauf hin dass diesmal eine ganz
normale amerikanische stadt gewesen sein
muss
die meisten gebäude sind verschwunden
aber das straßennetz ist noch da wir
müssen menschen gelebt haben überall ist
graffiti aber es ist nicht zu erkennen
was passiert ist sozusagen eine
geisterstadt ohne stadt
fundamente aber keine häuser eine
polizeiwache aber keine polizisten der
ort scheint einfach verschwunden zu sein
einige hinweise deuten auf eine
naturkatastrophe
riss im asphalt und bodenwellen hat es
hier ein erdbeben gegeben ist es deshalb
menschenleer wirklich seltsam
wer zum ersten mal her kommt könnte
glauben das vulkanische aktivität hinter
all den rissen und dem dampf steckt der
aus der erde kommt
was also ist hier wirklich geschehen
[Musik]
es ist schwer vorstellbar aber mitte des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts war die heutige
geisterstadt noch eine quicklebendige
gemeinde mit 1400 einwohnern und
funktionierender infrastruktur
ihr name central jahr
der journalist david die kopf kann sich
noch gut an bessere zeiten erinnern
diese aufnahme ist vom oktober 1983 wie
man sieht war das damals noch eine
intakte statt
das alles ging verloren
was dann geschah hätte sich selbst ein
erfindungsreicher autor kaum ausdenken
können
1979 wurde an der tankstelle von
centralia eine rätselhafte entdeckung
gemacht
musste seine tankstelle dichtmachen weil
die unterirdischen tanks zu heiß waren
er wehrte sich nicht dagegen obwohl er
mit seiner familie direkt über der
tankstelle wohnte für ihn stand viel auf
dem spiel
da denken ist nicht der einzige dem
rätselhaftes widerfährt
[Musik]
ein junge namens tom wolski spielte im
garten als sich plötzlich ein loch
auftat und er hinein fiel
er konnte sich gerade noch an einer
wurzel festhalten
er musste dann warten bis ein freund ihn
raus zog
er rettete ihm das leben in dem loch war
eine tödliche menge kohlenmonoxid danach
herrschte chaos der gouverneur wurde
informiert und das änderte alles
daraufhin kam die stadt im ganzen land
in die schlagzeilen
und es wird noch schlimmer
der boden hebt sich langsam
keiner wusste woher der rest stammte er
war etwa einen meter breit einen meter
tief und zehn meter lang
[Musik]
[Applaus]
woher kommen die löcher und risse
wüste spekulationen kursieren
die jahrelang kam kampf aus den riss auf
dem highway
die leute glaubten ein vulkan sei schuld
tatsächlich ist die ursache eine ganz
andere
es klingt unglaublich aber der grund ist
tatsächlich ein unterirdisches feuer es
brennt bereits seit 50 jahren
so kann gas durch die öffnungen im boden
zum beispiel in die keller der häuser
das gas war giftig und die flammen waren
immer in bewegung
das feuer wanderte unter dem highway
auf beiden seiten traten die siege
rauchwolken aus
[Musik]
1983 wird der highway gesperrt aber das
feuer brennt immer noch
das ist ein bohrloch wenn wir den deckel
abschrauben sehen wir was das feuer da
unten macht
ganz schön heiß die hitze kommt drauf
ich kann den schwefelgeruch des feuers
riechen und man sieht kleine wasser
fallen die steigen auf und schweben in
der luft ein experte sagte mir letztens
das in zehn metern tiefe eine temperatur
von 60 grad celsius gemessen wurde
wie ist das unterirdische inferno
entstanden
das hier sieht wie eine ganz normale
lichtung aus
1962 war hier eine große grube die als
mülldeponie diete
die feuerwehr hatte den auftrag das
ganze erst zu verbrennen und dann mit
wasser wegzuspülen
alles ganz einfach dachte man
war es aber nicht
etwas ungewöhnliches wurde ausgelöst ein
sogenannter kohle brand da unten ist
nämlich ein altes bergwerk
dorthin breiteten sich die flammen aus
damit fing alles an
[Musik]
in den folgenden 20 jahren brennt das
unterirdische feuer unbemerkt weiter
von oben kann man das weit verzweigte
bergwerk system unter der stadt nicht
erkennen
das ganze ding stand in flammen
mitten in einer der üppigsten kohle
regionen der welt es ist fast unmöglich
in dem weitläufigen labyrinth ein feuer
zu löschen
brände sind immer ein großes problem
sie destabilisieren die unterirdischen
tunnel und flöte und irgendwann auch die
oberfläche
so sind wahrscheinlich auch die
erdlöchern sein statt
alle versuche das feuer zu löschen sind
vergeblich
centralia wird zum nachrichten thema
auch die regierung schaltet sich ein
nach dem tod dombrowski in das loch
gefallen war gab es einen regelrechten
medienhype
verschiedene bürgerinitiativen forderten
eine evakuierung aber ist auch heute
noch zwei jahre bis etwas passierte
1984 werden alle einwohner central iaas
umgesiedelt sie erhalten 42 millionen
dollar unterstützung vom staat
[Musik]
bis auf eine handvoll hartgesottener
haben alle central jahr verlassen die
stadt wirkt fast so als hätte es sie nie
gegeben
man sieht wie schnell sich die natur die
stadt zurück holt sogar die straßen und
zufahrtswege nach und nach wird daraus
wieder wald
als ich zum ersten mal her kamen gab es
schon ein paar bäume aber nicht viele
jetzt wirkt es wie ein nationalpark
wie lange werden die unterirdischen
flammen noch wütend
[Musik]
schätzungen besagen noch 200 oder 250
jahre aber in wirklichkeit weiß es
keiner das feuer wird brennen bis
entweder die kohle oder der sauerstoff
aus geht beides wird nicht so schnell
passieren
[Musik]
sie zählten zum fortschrittlichsten was
ingenieurs und baukunst zu bieten hatten
heute sind sie nur noch ein echo der
historie sie erzählen von krieg und
terror aber auch von den großen erfolgen
der forschung und des menschlichen
strebens
[Musik]